i do have to uh ask because it just
happened that uh very sadly we lost uh
justice ruth bader ginsburg and
i i know you and i have talked about
this before
my mother one of the early women to go
to
yale law school and you uh went to law
school
and and and worked very hard and i'm
wondering
what her legacy means to you
where do i begin i mean you saw
through your experience with your mother
what it meant for women of her
generation
to go and obtain their law degree
at a time when women were not thought of
as being competent or smart enough to do
that
and the level of discrimination that
they faced
in law school and in their firms
afterwards
i just think about that and think about
the determination
and the sheer intelligence it took for
people
like justice ginsburg and your mother
and so many other women
well not many of them because there were
very few of them
in that generation um who were at the
front lines of
of of opening up opportunities for all
of us
and her entire legal career her time
on the supreme court um really
pushed open a new set of possibilities
for women all over the country and all
over the world
and to lose that kind of icon in this
time
that we're in because we are facing some
difficult times
is heartbreaking um but it
it should also be eye-opening um we
talk about in every election we talk
about
why it's important to vote and the
impact that who's in the oval office
makes to the supreme court in those
appointments
right sometimes that doesn't feel real
to people it's not motivating enough
because they're like well
what does this mean the supreme court a
lot of people don't understand but now
that we've lost
this icon and the balance of power in
the supreme court
lays in in the hands of
of of this sitting president and will
impact the lives of young people for
generations to come
it is all too real what having someone
like her
on the court has meant um but it makes
it plain
that we cannot take this election for
granted um
not now not ever um so
uh she was an icon a great role model to
me
and a dear friend to me and to barack
and she will be sorely missed